So all of my dogs and the dogs that come through
my rescue, Pup Culture Rescue,
have a little quirk.
I call it a quirk.
It's not an issue, you know.
It's not something to be judgmental about.
You just keep it in the back of your mind
that maybe they're a little shy or they don't like feet.
My other dog, he hates feet.
Like, if you just stretch out, it's like he saw a ghost.
So he was probably, unfortunately kicked or something
before I adopted him.
It's amazing how they can be so forgiving of humans
after some human out there has put them through such trauma.
So, what is a good way to foster a dog?
I would say go straight to your organization.
But beyond that, what your advice?
Totally.
It's a great way to meet people
and the community is so amazing.
Check out Petfinder, Adoptapet.com.
Social media is amazing.
Just search for your local rescue.
We need fosters so badly,
because without fosters
we can't pull more dogs off the streets or out of shelters.
So, if you have a little extra time
and you can open your home up,
it is an excellent way to give back.
(upbeat music)